que david rigoulet roze chercheur
spécialiste du moyen-orient associé à
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques rédacteur en chef
également de la revue orient stratégique
bonsoir david bridoux les roses merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
et autorités libanaises qui durcissent
donc le ton en promettant des
arrestations pour les actes de
vandalisme quels messages ont voulu
faire passer les autorités selon vous
oui une attitude perceptible de la part
des autorités qui vont l'impression que
la situation est susceptible de leur
échapper et c'est vrai que ces derniers
jours les diverses manifestations que ce
soit beyrouth ou à tripoli ont montré
qu'il y avait eu une modification par
rapport à aux manifestations initiale
des premières semaines en octobre
on n'est plus du tout dans l'esprit
salmiya c'est à dire des manifestations
pacifiques il ya une violence qui est en
train de monter alors évidemment il ya
les galeux l'affichage d'un discours
complotistes
on est en orient c'est très souvent il
ya effectivement l'idée qu'ils auraient
une main invisible qui serait derrière
les diverses manifestations violentes
il ya des tensions incontestable au
niveau politique parce que derrière la
nomination du premier ministre hassan
diab il ya eu des difficultés 1 pour la
mise en place du gouvernement à partir
de janvier dernier
mais on sort de là de la période aussi
de parce qu'on est dans la période post
kobe d'un et les problèmes qu'ils
étaient prêts existants prennent un tour
absolument dramatique c'est à dire avec
des vagues de licenciements massifs
il ya un effondrement du pip qui est
prévu plus de 12% 45% la population est
aujourd'hui passé sous le seuil de la
pauvreté et donc il ya il ya une
dimension clairement émeutes de la faim
qui commencent à surgir et qui est
effectivement problématique pour les
autorités politiques
vous décrivez évidemment cette situation
politique dramatique on liban dont on
parle depuis longtemps effectivement
avant même le kobe 19 comment le pays
peut-il désormais son sens relevé on
parle beaucoup de l'intervention du fmi
est ce que c'est une piste que les
libanais accueille avec
bienveillance le problème c'est que le
liban n'a pas tu n as pas de marge de
manoeuvre si dire que au début mars
dernier le premier ministre a dit qu'il
ne pouvait pas assurer le remboursement
d'une partie de la dette de l'ordre de 1
milliard et demi en drôme ont donc
c'était une manière de signifier un
défaut sur la dette libanaise avec en
arrière-plan évidemment ce qui se
profile c'est la dévaluation de la
monnaie et la dévaluation elle est déjà
dans les faits puisque au marché noir
effectivement elle est passée à 1 $ pour
5000 livres
alors même si les autorités ont injecté
des dollars pour faire baisser
effectivement le le les villes pour
limiter la baisse du pouvoir d'achat si
ça n'est que partie remise et donc la
situation effectivement est dramatique
et il ya une personnalité qui est visé
c'est le le celle de mai le directeur de
la banque centrale riad salamé
effectivement qui est accusé d'avoir
fait une certaine manière valider un
système un modèle économique qui a
conduit aujourd'hui à la situation qu'on
connaît au liban aujourd'hui comment
peut-on se sortir de ça on sait que des
manifestants demandent voilà un
changement de système un changement de
personne au gouvernement la fin de la
corruption est ce que les autorités ont
pris quand même les mesures de ces
appels de colère très persistant et qui
datent pas d'hier
oui c'est le premier ministe d'ailleurs
a dit qu'il entamait la guerre contre la
corruption mais que ça allait très
difficile parce qu'il ya une résistance
de ceux qui sont partie prenante de ce
système et aux la vérité c'est que tout
le liban ait échoué à eux repose sur une
grande partie sur un système de
népotisme et de corruption et donc c'est
extrêmement difficile de changer de
paradigme
surtout dans une situation aussi
dramatique que celle d'aujourd'hui et il
y avait évidemment des aides qu'elle
était proposé avec la conférence cèdre
en avril 2018 à paris mais c'était
souhaitait conditionner par un certain
nombre de réformes structurelles qui
n'ont jamais été mené depuis
et là on sait la quadrature du cercle
effectivement pour le gouvernement
actuel qui n'a plus du tout de marge de
manoeuvre
et qui se retrouve confronté à une
situation qui n'a plus rien à voir une
certaine manière avec avec une dimension
strictement politique comme ça a pu
l'être à partir du 17 octobre
là on est clairement dans une logique
délétère avec des violences qui sont
susceptibles de dégénérer et où tout le
monde est profondément inquiet parce que
grande partie de la population n'a tout
simplement plus les moyens de subvenir à
ses besoins
la question peut paraître naïve mais
elle est importante parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a parfois du mal à comprendre
cette situation d'un pays aussi riche à
tous les niveaux riche en ressources
riches en diversité
comment expliquer ce gâchis ni
aujourd'hui alors riche en diversité
c'est incontestable notamment
confessionnelles d'ailleurs s'explique
une grande partie du système qui a été
mis en place
de répartition d'expression politique au
fessionnels pour le reste est plus
sujette à caution puisque le liban ne
produit rien et c'est tout le problème
il a fondé sa prospérité un peu fictif
sur un système de ponzi on va dire c'est
à dire qu'il reposait sur des taux
d'intérêt de la banque centrale
justement à deux chiffres qui étaient
très spéculatif et qui faisait rentrer
artificiellement de l'argent mais à
partir du moment où il ya une défiance
par rapport à cette donne effectivement
financière et bancaire
le liban se retrouve finalement exemple
et n'est plus aux moyens de payer tout
simplement les importations qui sont de
l'ordre de 90% du pays et donc là là on
se retrouve dans la situation qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui
oracle question en dernière question
quelles sont les réactions des pays
voisins qu'elle peut-être leur marge de
manoeuvre est leur rôle
bayer des grandes inquiétudes et
d'ailleurs on peut pas dissocier la
situation libanaise de la situation
syrienne
parce que la crise qui aujourd'hui
secoue la syrie est en partie lié
d'ailleurs à ce défaut sur le système
bancaire libanais puisque les deux
avaient partie liée
pendant très longtemps les lois
américaines de sanctions américaines qui
a eu qui la loi césar qui rentre en
vigueur justement contre la syrie
aujourd'hui qui va peser encore plus et
indirectement qui auront un impact aussi
sur l'évolution de la situation
financière est bonne à dire libanaise
merci david rigaud les roses d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
évoquer donc cette situation ol les
bancs